JUST IN TEXAS THROUGHOUT TEXAS
AND THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE
NATION.
GRIFF: AND MIKE AND JAQUI,
WE’RE LUCKY TO BE JOINED BY THE
PREVIOUS SURE IN TEXAS, AND WE
MET YEARS AGO RIDING ON AIR
BOATS DURING HURRICANE HARVEY,
BUT YOU KNOW, FELL WELL, TASKED
WITH PROTECTING RIVERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO SAY AND
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE CRISIS
THAT WE’RE SEEING HERE?
>> YOU KNOW, THANK YOU GRIFF
FOR HAVING ME, I’VE HAD
OPPORTUNITIES TO VISIT THIS
BORDER, McALLEN, LAREDO, I’VE
BEEN TO YUMA.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS PLAYING
POLITICS WITH THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE, IT’S DANGEROUS.
I’VE NOTICED THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS IN COMPLETE
DENIAL.
JUST LAST WEEK, KAMALA HARRIS
SAID SHE WAS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, THAT’S A DOWNRIGHT LIE.
GETS IN FRONT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND SAYS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER IS SECURE.
THAT IS A LIE.
I COULD PUT HIM ON A POLYGRAPH
MACHINE AND HE WOULD FAIL IT,
MAYOR
MAYORKAS AND SO WOULD KAMALA
HARRIS.
IF KAMALA HARRIS AND MAYORKAS
STOOD ON THIS BANK I WONDER
WHAT THEY WOULD SAY ABOUT WHAT
THEY SAID TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THIS BORDER IS CLOSED,
I’VE BEEN TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, THEY HAVEN’T AND
THEY’RE PLAYING WITH THE LIVES
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT’S
DANGEROUS.
THE PEOPLE COMING ACROSS HERE
ARE THE ONES THAT ACTUALLY ARE
WAVING THE WHITE FLAG.
THEY KNOW YOU’RE HERE.
THEY KNOW DPS IS HERE AND THE
BORDER AGENTS ARE HERE.
THEY WANT TO BE APPREHENDED, SO
TO SPEAK, BECAUSE THEY KNOW
IT’S A WELCOME RIGHT INTO OUR
GREAT COUNTRY OF OURS, BUT WHAT
ABOUT THE THOUSANDS THAT ARE
COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER UNDER THE COVER OF
DARKNESS?
THOSE ARE THE ONES BRINGING IN
THE DRUGS, FENTANYL AND
METHAMPHETAMINE AND IT’S
KILLING PEOPLE.
SO WE HAVE TO--
IF YOU’RE GOING TO SOLVE THIS
ISSUE, NUMBER ONE, YOU HAVE TO
BE REAL, YOU HAVE TO WAKE UP
AND REALIZE WHAT’S HAPPENING
HERE, YOU HAVE TO VISIT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT YOU’VE GOT
TO REVERT BACK TO TRUMP’S
POLICIES, THAT’S THE ONLY WAY
YOU’RE GOING TO HANDLE IT.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU MENTIONED
THE DRUGS AND CVP PUT OUT
COCAINE SEIZURE, EXCEEDED LAST
YEAR.
FENTANYL 7500 POUNDS AND
EXCEEDED LAST YEAR.
AND 25 MILLION A WEEK JUST IN
THIS AREA, THE CARTELS ARE
MAKING ON HUMANS.
IT’S NOT FACTORING IN THE DRUGS
AND IS IT YOUR OPINION, YOUR
BELIEF THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS IN SOME WAY ENABLING THE
CARTELS TO PROFIT?
>> NUMBER ONE, I BELIEVE THAT
THIS HAVE --
ADMINISTRATION, I’VE BEEN ON
THE PROGRAM TALKING ABOUT LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT CLEANING UP THE
MESS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS COMPLICIT.
THEY’RE AIDING AND ABETTING IN
THE CRIME OF TRAFFICKING
PERSONS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
THEY KNOW WHAT’S TAKING PLACE,
NOW, WE TALK IN THIS COUNTRY
ABOUT THE WAR ON DRUGS, AND WE
DO PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENTS, TALKING ABOUT
SEX TRAFFICKING, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, LABOR TRAFFICKING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS HAPPENING
WHEN THESE PEOPLE ENTER OUR
COUNTRY?
ENTER OUR GREAT COUNTRY OF
OURS, MANY OF THEM DON’T SPEAK
ENGLISH, RIGHT?
THEY’RE GOING TO COME ACROSS
HERE, HAVE LIMITED SKILLS.
THEY’RE BEHOLDEN TO THE
TRAFFICKERS, RIGHT AND MANY OF
THEM MAY HAVE A DEBT TO PAY SO
THEY’RE GOING TO BE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND THEY’RE GOING TO BE
DOING THINGS THAT THEY DON’T
WANT TO DO BECAUSE IF THEY
DON’T PAY THAT BILL IN FULL,
THE DRUG SMUGGLERS AND THE
TRAFFICKING AND COYOTES WILL
THREATEN TO KILL THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> CONGRESSMAN QUICK BEFORE WE
RUN OUT OF TIME HERE AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
YOUR GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR ABBOTT
SAYS HE’LL ALLOCATE A BILLION
DOLLARS TO FIGHT THIS CRISIS
AND POSSIBLY TRY AND BUILD A
WALL IF THE ADMINISTRATION
WON’T?
>> IT’S SAD THE TAXPAYERS OF
TEXAS ARE USING DOLLARS FROM
TEXAS UP TO A BILLION DOLLARS.
IT’S THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT’S
RESPONSIBILITY, SPECIFICALLY
CONGRESS TO SECURE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
I UNDERSTAND WHY THE GOVERNOR
IS DOING IT, HE’S THERE AND HIS
CHARGE IS TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
IN THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS
BECAUSE OUR PRESIDENT AND
ADMINISTRATION IS UNWILLING TO
DO SO-SO I UNDERSTAND HIS POINT
AND I HOPE IT CAN BE EFFECTIVE
AND I’M SURE THAT DPS THEY’RE
DOING THE BEST TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE, BUT IF YOU
REALLY, REALLY WANT TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE AND STOP THE WAR,
PREVENT SOME OF THE DRUGS
COMING IN AND THESE ILLEGALS,
YOU HAVE TO SECURE THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH A WALL, REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY.
THAT’S IT, YOU HAVE TO DO IT
AND YOU HAVE TO DO IT NOW.